je suis très embêté je suis très embêté
que j'avais peu par un truc qui j'espère
aura pu vous sensibiliser et puis en
fait on m'a donné consigne et moi j'ai
joué au rugby et au rugby on joue avec
l'équipe on fait ce qu'on nous dit ce
que nous dit l'entraîneur et d'ailleurs
on m'a dit des trucs et j'ai pas dormi
de la nuit avec ça parce qu'en fait il
ya des règles et en fait ces règles si
on n'y adhèrent pas faut vraiment de
transgresser parce que je crois que le
secret du bonheur c'est de surtout ne
pas faire ce qu'on n'a pas envie de
faire
alors hier je me suis fait rnt je
donnerai pas de noms je les connais tous
si je réglerai mes problèmes après il ya
un truc je me suis aperçu dans ma vie
avait deux tués pour essayer d'être
heureux et puis pour avoir une relation
sympa avec des autres c'était un de
sourire et deux de dire bonjour et moi
on m'a dit surtout tu dis pas bonjour
alors je voulais vous dire ce soir
bonjour a tous voila
bon maintenant on va rentrer dans le dur
alors je suis producteur d'huîtres c'est
mon vrai métier
c'est ce qui m'a fabriqué c'est mon
histoire ça fait cette génération je
pense que les huit c'est un peu
génétique si on posait de l'adn je pense
comme trouver des trucs de grâce aux
très agile gaz dans mais dans mes jeunes
je fais ça sur le bassin d'arcachon où
je suis né j'ai vécu sur le bassin
jusqu'à vingt trois ans et j'ai un très
bon ami un homme que j'aime beaucoup qui
est un vrai poète qui s'appelle jean
louis aubert qui avec une très belle
chanson qui s'appelle des plages
et qui dit que sur toutes les pages du
monde il ya des enfants qui regarde de
l'autre côté et qui pensent que le
paradis c'est là bas ça a été mon cas
donc je fais mes tours de piste j'ai à
peu près fait le tour du monde en dehors
de l'amérique du sud
et puis j'ai appris que mon paradis en
fait c'était chez moi sur le bassin
d'arcachon
donc je suis un homme chanceux heureux
et sur ce bassin qui m'a nourri puisque
c'est mon métier mais j'ai eu aussi de
grandes peines puisque j'avais une
entreprise familiale que je me suis
trouvé un moment de ma vie
confronté à la pire des situations
c'est à dire était réunie la bêtise le
cynisme l'incompétence et la lâcheté et
quand vous avez en face je vous promets
que vous êtes totalement désarmés
c'était une administration qui a piqué
sain ça m'a coûté une entreprise donc à
50 ans j'ai arrêté une entreprise qui
était une entreprise familiale depuis
sept générations
et lun c'est arrivé en 2005 cette
aventure
en 2005 je savais que mon histoire était
fini c'est à dire c'était chronique
d'une mort annoncée pour faire court
quand vous perdez trois cent mille euros
dans une entreprise d'une année quel que
soit le talent goût déployer c'est très
difficile à reconstituer donc je savais
en 2005 que globalement 2006 2007 ou
2008 mon histoire allait s'arrêter
et là j'ai découvert un truc c'est que
la pire des situations
c'est l imaginaire c'est à dire la peur
imaginaire de s'imaginer ce qu'allait
être la disgrâce de s'imaginer de caisse
que vont penser les autres puisqu'on
sait que c'est fini que ça va s'arrêter
mais tant qu'on n'y est pas encore on
n'est pas confronté
donc on s'imagine à un moment ça va
finir ça va ça va être rude qu'est ce
qu'on attendait de moi je suis une
vieille famille du bassin qu'est ce
qu'est ce que je vais devenir
financièrement je vais faire quoi je
vais fouiller quoi bouffer à ma fille
enfin j'étais vraiment dans une dans un
système de peur qui est extrêmement
pressant et on vous en a parlé d'autres
intervenants vous en ont parlé la peur
est la peur imaginaire c'est à dire que
pas là la peur où on est confronté aux
choses ce qu'on s'imagine que de ce que
va être la disgrâce c'est bien pire que
la disgrâce
parce que la disgrâce quand on vous y
êtes dans la merde je veux c'est court
et quand on est dans la merde on n'a pas
le choix on peut plus poser les
questions pour trouver les réponses
et puis faut surtout se bouger parce que
parce que si on se bouge pas c'est là
pis là pour le coup c'est la fin de tout
et si j'ai pu traverser ces périodes
très difficiles
je pense que c'est lié à trois
phénomènes qui ont à peu près bâti ma
vie ça a été le bassin d'arcachon qui
est un espace qui m'a donné beaucoup de
force parce que tout petit pardon
toujours l'émotion je parle du passé
hop soul en fait donc ce bassin j'y
reviens c'est un espace où j'ai grandi
dans un petit village
j'ai été élevé en liberté comme les
poulets sont sauvés c'est à dire qu'à
cinq ans je me barre est dans mon
village vous partez un kilomètre de chez
moi y'a pas de risque que c'était que ma
famille et que les boisés on se
connaissait tous on était dans un pays
de cocagne
moi je savais pas moi par contre à cinq
ans de partir à un kilomètre je me
prenais pour vasco de gamma gt gt le roi
du monde et cette espèce de d'élevage en
liberté pour les poulets de set sauvées
il faut penser aux acteurs et sept
espèces d'élevage dans liberté m'a
appris à vivre sans peur sans peur de
s'y risquer y avoir c'est là que j'ai
été confronté à des peurs je suis tombé
sur des serpents je suis tombé à l'eau
je suis parti à la dérive en bateau donc
j'ai eu des peurs mais j'étais confronté
je les gérer au moment que j'étais
dessus mais je n'étais pas dans le truck
jamais on m'a dit vas pas là tu vas te
faire écraser sans pas ne répondent pour
monsieur k le manteau et katchoo verts
on m'a jamais dit ça donc j'ai toujours
été élevé avec une avec de la légèreté
voilà avec de la légèreté est bon le
problème ma mère quand j'étais petit il
me disait tout ce que tu vois c'est à
toi tu as deux bras deux jambes le monde
ne t'appartient et c'est vrai que le
monde nous appartient le monde nous
appartient sur leurs gardes
si on est attentionné aux autres et moi
quand je suis sorti de mon village est
un bourgeois paysans gt il reste que 80
où il est toujours naze ce truc est donc
donc j'étais mme bourgeois paysans et ma
première confrontation aux autres c'est
au service militaire fait j'ai débarqué
jeteurs gentil petit minet du coin à 19
ans on va couper les cheveux on a
déguisé en mickey on a mis un peu d'eau
sur la tête et on a fait marcher au pas
et on m'expliquer en manque de laon
qu'il fallait que je fasse des pompes et
quand on est fine et m'engueuler on
aurait engueulé et on était 180 dans une
piaule où on n'avait aucun code c'est à
dire qu'on était 180 mec pas de corps de
rien qui nous rassemble rien qui nous
permette nous identifier ou de ne
reconnaître et dans cet environnement
face à l'adversité dégradé qui nous
faisait courir et qui nous faisait
souffrir se sont regroupés des noyaux de
gens mais on s'est reconnus justes sur
le regard sur le feeling sur ce qui nous
semblait que telle autre et sur les
perceptions qui était complètement dénué
de connivence de code de est en fait au
bout de quelques jours on s'est aperçu
que bon il ne faut que la pression était
un peu tombé quand on maîtrise un peu le
milieu on s'est mis à parler de ce qu'on
était et j'ai découvert avec stupeur que
mes meilleurs amis choisis pour le coup
était des gens savent étaient mes
voisins de palier dans mon village je
crois que je le regrette jamais parler
tellement il me ressemble un peu et
tellement ils n'avaient pas les mêmes
cordes que moi et de ce jour là je me
suis mis à regarder le monde avec avec
un autre oeil
et je me suis mis à regarder surtout le
regard des jambes parce que l'armée
c'est ce qui m'a permis de trouver mais
mes amis et je me suis mis à regarder le
regard des jambes pas saboter pas son
expression la manière dont les gens me
posent leur regard sur les autres sur
les choses et ça ça dit tout sur
l'humanité des individus le deuxième un
truc qui m'intéresse aussi beaucoup dans
la rencontre des gens c'est la manière
dont il parle des autres j'ai pas si
vous avez remarqué mais il ya des gens
comme qui parle des autres c'est pour
dire du mal et vous apercevez que
finalement comme disent du mal de leur
avoue dès que vous êtes parti ça va être
votre tour et il ya une très belle
phrase de spinoza qui disque pierre dit
sur paul en dit plus sur pierre que sur
paul et je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec ça écouter les gens parlaient
comment il parle des autres et vous
allez savoir quelle est la couleur de
leur âme dans la couleur pas totalement
même pas vous allez avoir des tendances
lourdes
donc tous ces événements ont fait que
j'ai croisé beaucoup beaucoup de gens
sans pression c'est à dire que ça c'est
peut-être un handicap génétique
je n'ai quasiment jamais de pression
j'ai de l'émotion la vue sur le bassin
tout à l'heure mais du de la pression
jamais peint et donc le fait de pas
avoir de pression m'a permis d'aborder
les autres sans parano rien sans peur et
je crois que le regard qu'on pose sur
les autres induit le regard de l'autre
je pense que si on a un regard qui a
peur l'autre en face va avoir peur et
délaissé ses communicants et le fait
d'avoir ça ça m'a amené dans plein
d'aventurés que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure le cinéma la chambre de commerce
de bordeaux ou de leurs hommes à la
martinique le directeur commercial d'une
boîte de rome est en fait finalement
salsa crespin d'opportunités et comme
j'aime bien les aventures et des chalets
selon me proposer un truc si ça me
plaisait je partais et si je raconte ça
c'est pas pour vous dire tout ce que
j'ai fait c'est pour dire que ce qui est
important ce n'est pas d'avoir réussi ou
d'avoir eu un échec dans ce qu'on a fait
ce qui est important c'est le voyage
qu'on a fait pour y arriver parce qu'en
fait quand que vous arriviez à la
réussite ou à l'échec
quand vous êtes à ce terme c'est la fin
de la première histoire et c'est le
début d'une deuxième histoire qui
commence
or ce qui est intéressant c'est le
chemin qu'on fait pour arriver à la
réussite ou à l'échec et les deux sont
aussi constructeur pour moi parce que
les deux amène des leçons qui sont des
leçons différentes
donc si j'avais un message à donner
qu'on gagne ou qu'on perde c'est pas
très important kipling a fait un très
beau poème qui s'appelle tu as fait ça
finira tu seras un homme mon fils je
pourrais vous le faire en anglais mais
ça va être long et il ya deux phrases de
diaby est de passage qui dit si tu peux
voir détruit ouvrage de ta vie et sans
dire un seul mot honteux mettre à
rebâtir et si tu peux affronter triomphe
après des fêtes et prendre ses deux
moteurs d'un même front tu seras un
homme mon fils et je pense que ça c'est
vrai donc il faut garder la pêche
garder l'espoir le monde est merveilleux
si on s'est regardé ce qui est beau
quand j'étais en l'amer de noir nostri
culture on avait des c était vraiment
tendu quand je lui ai tendu tendu et
j'avais de mes confrères qui étaient
déprimés on avait des levers de soleil
où il est mort le soleil
on avait des levers de soleil comme ça
c'est bien la peine et que vous fassiez
qui avait beau truc là ça marche même
quand m et donc quand vous avez ça le
matin même si vous avez la tête dans le
noir et que vous avez pas d'avenir ça je
vous jure il n'y a pas nui c'est qu'il
voulait pendre a donc ça c'est un moment
de bonheur et tous les moments de
bonheur pour les savourer voilà je vous
remercie je vous embrasse